Jason Alexander is unquestionably best
known for one role but what a role it
was high-strung lucky loser George
Costanza on Seinfeld
he was just 29 when the show premiered
in 1989 playing an iconic character
early in one's career can be a
double-edged sword sure the job security
money and being a part of TV history are
nice but it's hard for an audience to
accept actors and other roles after
they're so closely associated with one
familiar character believe it or not
Alexander has had a colorful balanced
and sometimes glamorous career after
Seinfeld here's what he's been up to
recently cursed to fail for years there
was talk of a Seinfeld curse which
seemed to affect the former cast of that
classic comedy everyone's first post
Seinfeld projects tanked Julia
louis-dreyfus is watching Ellie Michael
Richards the Michael Richards show and a
pair of Jason Alexander shows first up
was Bob Patterson a short-lived 2000 ABC
sitcom about a motivational speaker
whose personal life was a mess
my colleague Bob Patterson it was a
constant reminder that there is more to
life than success then came listen up
which followed a fictionalized version
of sports radio host Tony Kornheiser
who's a big shot at work but has a
dysfunctional personal life both shows
lasted less than a year taking charge
few people know episodic TV better than
Jason Alexander Seinfeld featured more
complicated direction than most
traditional sitcoms in the 90s thus
Alexander's experience on that show
makes him uniquely qualified to direct
television and that's what he does now
he sound episodes of everything from the
improv heavy campus ladies to the single
camera Everybody Hates Chris to
tried-and-true sitcom fare like Mike and
Molly and even dramas like Criminal
Minds he also directed that appeared in
country star Brad Paisley's music video
for the hit song online song and dance
man before Seinfeld premiered Alexander
was a theater guy in the 80s he starred
in plenty of New York stage fare
including Jerome Robbins Broadway which
earned him a Tony Award for Best Actor
in a musical
after Seinfeld concluded in
1998 he returned to the footlights
starring as Max Bialystock in the first
national tour of the producers he also
notably had a starring role in the 2015
play fish in the dark which was written
by Seinfeld co-creator Larry David if I
came to see the play would you want me
to come backstage on the road on stage
like other well-known comic actors that
came before him Alexander hit the stage
with an autobiographical one-person show
entitled an evening with Jason Alexander
and his hair described as a hilarious
retelling of his journey to and on the
Broadway stage
Alexander sing-songs tells jokes and
does a little crowd work he also wears a
completely bogus hairpiece for the
performance he's toured the show off and
on in casinos and theatres around the
world since 2014 on the road on TV there
are so many networks cranking out
high-quality TV these days that it's
easy to overlook even a show starring a
Seinfeld veteran since the fall of 2017
Alexander has starred on the audience
network's hit the road which he
co-created he plays a dad in search of
higher meaning in his life who forces
his family into a rock band style tour
bus to drive around the country let's go
shoot up and start sizing start setting
suited up suited up the
israeli-palestinian conflict Alexander
was raised in a Jewish home and he has
worked extensively with a group aiming
to broker understanding in Israel in
2004 he helped launch the one voice
campaign which enabled regular
Palestinians and Israelis living in
disputed areas to vote online for peace
and settlement initiatives Alexander's
work with the campaign has included
public appearances and promotional
videos piece together now to rich to
work too hard
Alexander hit the showbiz jackpot with
Seinfeld not only was it a creatively
fulfilling role on a hit sitcom for
which he earned multiple Emmy
nominations and lasting Fame but he was
also handsomely paid in the final season
alone he earned $600,000 in F
factoring in is cut from endless reruns
on syndication and online streaming
Alexander is reportedly worth millions
today if we don't see him on screens too
much anymore perhaps it's because he can
afford to be selective with his time
well the jerk you're their all-time best
seller
[Laughter]